glv bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir thiery alors
dieudonné et vous serez le 29 décembre
sur la scène du zénith de paris avec
votre nouveau spectacle intitulé mes
excuses et ensuite en tournée dans toute
la france voilà alors mes excuses
pourquoi c'est suite au sketch que vous
aviez fait dans une émission qui
s'appelle on ne peut pas plaire à tout
le monde
c'est le cas de le dire c'était réussi
où vous êtes apparu déguisé en juif
orthodoxe avec une cagoule en disant
j'encourage les jeunes gens aujourd'hui
dans les cités pour leur dire
convertissez vous comme moi
essayez de vous ressaisir rejoignez-les
axe du bien
l' axe américano sioniste et vous aviez
conclu par un israël israël ou et ouais
ouais ouais c'était c'est un sketch que
j'ai fait car il est bien fonctionné un
dd de notoriété internationale
j'ai même eu ma face dans les tribunes
ouais tu as dieudonné armes anglais et
tout d'un coup j'ai de beaux j'étais une
merde internationale il a fallu s'y
faire c'est ma mère était assez fier on
vous reconnaissez que vous avez fait des
sketches plus marrant quand même oui
mais je trouve que c'est un sketch qui
était important il ya ouvert en tout cas
un vrai débat en tout cas dans les
tribunaux est ce que ça vous a convaincu
de mieux préparer vos sketches à
l'avenir oui mais en même temps je sais
j'ai rien à me reprocher la justice mam
a donné raison j'avais le droit de le
faire
on est dans un état de droit c'est la
justice qui décide et qui détermine les
limites alors dieudo c'était il ya un an
en un an
combien de procès perdu aucun pour dire
que vraiment encore une fois c'est un
malentendu regrettable malentendu on va
voir combien de lettres d' insulte pas
mal mais change est un habitué
j'avais déjà sorti un premier un bouquin
je commentais ses oeuvres et
et là j'ai de moi et j'ai de quoi en
faire au moins trois quatre volumes
combien de lettres de soutien beaucoup
merci plus ou moins beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus c'était d'ailleurs la
grande surprise c'est de voir que en
fait il ya la rumeur médiatique les
médias qui vivent un peu repliés sur eux
mêmes
et puis la réalité du terrain ouais
jouer sur scène un peu partout et puis
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un soutien
vraiment très très très chaleureux donc
je remercie encore une fois tout le
public qui m'a permis de continuer à
faire le métier que j'aime et c'était le
plus important
combien les spectacles annulés -une dit
une quinzaine s'inquiète pas mal en
province alors que la justice était
était favorable à ce que ces spectacles
donc c'était vraiment sous la pression
la menace des menaces de violence
trouble à l'ordre public on a blessé une
petite fille de 13 ans que je salue la à
lyon qui était venu voir mon spectacle
un certain monsieur dubé tard qu'il
acquit la violente et de l'homme a été
relâché immédiatement bon j'ai expliqué
aux parents ils avaient le tort d'être
marocain il peut rien combien d'amis
perdu pas beaucoup n'ont pas beaucoup
beaucoup d'amis gagner pas beaucoup non
plus ouais comme l excuse perforation
personne ne s'est excusé
alors que la justice mme donné raison se
trouve ça un petit peu regrettable parce
qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui sont montés
au créneau
à un moment donné j'étais devenu l'axé
du mal à marc elsen vous pensez pas que
c'était à vous deux excuses et non en
dix ans le sketch était pas très drôle
je suis désolé si j'ai blessé des gens
voient là excusez moi voilà c'est une
connerie c'est un dérapage non mais en
sortant de ce sketch c'est ce que j'ai
dit immédiatement là je vous parle des
excuses vous vous pensez aux autres
ah oui vous vous pensez pas à vous ah
ben non je pense à l'injustice qu dont
j'ai été victime puisque la justice m'a
donné raison
ouais j'ai vécu avant une injustice ce
n'est pas juste de me condamner comme on
l'avait fait donc je n'ai pour l'instant
pas eu les excuses de monsieur perben de
monsieur bernard henri lévy les
messieurs bénichou et tout ce groupe
mais vous n'avez pas eu envie de vous
excuser un spontanément à la sortie de
ce sketch est ce que j'ai fait j'ai dit
moi si j'ai heurté des gens je suis
désolé mais je ne recommencerai puisque
c'est mon travail c'est mais vous ne
feriez pas le même sketch quand même
mais le spectacle que je fais
reprend en grande partie les lignes de
ce sketch il est mieux travailler
visiblement puisque ont fait salle
comble depuis théâtre de la main d'or
des jo qu'on se connaît depuis longtemps
moi j'ai souvent militer pour vous
puissiez vous exprimer
mais il ya un truc que je comprends pas
sur cette affaire c'est qu'à aucun
moment vous avez senti le besoin de vous
excuser et que vous en avez rajouté
surtout c'est à dire que vous avez à
partir de la jante il ya un an
là si vous avez vous avez fait tout un
tas de déclarations sur le lobby juif
qui tient les médias j'ai fait parler de
lobby juif par exemple jamais assis non
j'ai été soutenu j'ai parlé de danger
parler de lobby sioniste n 'est pas la
même chose il ya beaucoup de juifs
aujourd'hui qui sont malheureusement
otages du sionisme qui est un projet
politique qui n'a rien à voir avec la
religion juive d'un projet impérialiste
raciste qui ce petit mec il ya un vrai
soutien ici et je me suis étonné
effectivement de ce soutien et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut le dire il ya
beaucoup et je suis soutenue par pas mal
de gens et beaucoup de juifs notamment
quelques rabbins qui sont dus me
soutenir il ya encore quelques jours on
les emmène en mai nous nous sommes on
pense on que dieudonné au contraire son
sketch était très utile et qu'il faut
installer le dialogue aujourd'hui sur un
sujet aussi sensible et si difficile et
si le rire mieux doucement essayer de
s'immiscer dans vous avez quand même
dénoncé un animateur de télévision un
chanteur qui soutiennent l'armée
israélienne
ça c'est la vérité c'est vrai il ya des
manifestations pour le soutien de deux
salles et je trouve qu'on est à moi je
suis français
bon je n'ai pas de religion je partis à
la république pour moi je me soumets à
la loi la justice de ce pays et je
trouve ça étonnant qu'on puisse à vue de
faire des manifestations de soutien il
emmène une armée après le sketch que
vous avez fait sur france 3 et vous
déclarez trois semaines après d'un
journal du dimanche que les juifs ce
sont des négriers reconvertis dans la
banque la richesse que j'aimerais bons
jeux les jeux les emmener hilarant
coulisses l'article parce que c'est ça
je n'ai jamais dit ça je répondais à aux
journalistes et au lendemain de
l'agression dont le public a été victime
à lyon aider des gens du betar ces sites
une organisation
une sorte de milice pro pro sharon quoi
très très virulente
ils sont rentrés dans la salle en criant
'dieu d'eau sale [ __ ] les juifs auront
à pau qu'est ce que voulez que je
réponde à sa libre et ce sont des
négriers reconvertis dans l'action
terroriste
c'est pas du tout et on en a déduit
dieudonné alice et son décès je n'ai
jamais parlé de les juifs je n'ai jamais
fait d' amalgame jamais eric c'est là où
c'est si je l'avais fait cet amalgame la
justice n'aurait certainement déclaré
coupable or je ne les ai pas fait donc
la justice ne pourra pas mais c'est sous
ces petites nuances qui sont gênantes
parce qu'elles sont reprises et pourquoi
donc tant dans le même sens sur ça et
vous vous êtes un journal et vous vous
savez bien vous connaissez bien aussi
mais la la la la la puissance de la
rumeur et qu'elle peut être entretenue
elle peut être là en l'occurrence c'est
faux dans les enfants qu'il avait
entretenu la rumeur ah je vous avais
moi-même et je les aime en asie ce que
vous me dites vous rendez bien compte
que c'est compliqué c'est ce qui était
imprimé dans le journal du dimanche
si on pouvait m'amener là l'article
vraiment génial à dieudo il va là non
c'est important alors l'inquiéter contre
la censure d'internet excuse moi je
reviens sur le truc bon c'est du direct
donc j'ai un peu peur de le casser le
rythme voilà donc un homme a été arrêté
qui a fait partie des mouvements
d'extrême droite sioniste raciste et
xénophobe salle nerfs les juifs auront à
pau voilà le genre de slogans que j'ai
entendu ce sont tous ces négriers
reconvertis aujourd'hui dans l'action
terroriste qui manifestent leur soutien
à la politique d'ariel sharon voilà ce
que j'ai dit
delap ce sont tous ces négriers
reconvertis reconvertir gardois
convertis dans quoi attarder un homme a
été arrêté qui fait partie voilà je ris
jaune a même été arrêtés qui fait partie
de ces mouvements d'extrême droite
sioniste raciste et xénophobe salaires
les juifs auront à pau voilà le genre de
slogans que j'ai entendu ce sont tous
ces négriers reconvertis dans la banque
dans le spectacle est aujourd'hui dans
l'action terroriste qui manifestent leur
soutien la politique d'ariel sharon je
vous rappelle que ces gens sont entrés à
150 ont tapé l'ex les jambes à sursaut
je vous dis que c'est la banque c'est
que c'est la banque alors que vous c'est
la banque qui vous sinon c'est la banque
dans le journal mois non c'est le choc
qui vous gène nommé tmc l'ensemble ce
qui est gênant c'est important non mais
c'est parce que moi je vous dis je vous
dira la jeunesse demain l'intégralité la
dut donc si vous dites les juifs tout à
l'heure vous avez dit vous avez dit que
les juifs sont des négriers reconvertis
dans la banque alors que je dis ce sont
tous ces gens dont je parle des ces gens
qui m'ont traité de dieudo sale [ __ ]
les juifs auront apogée quand même le
droit de leur répondre ouais vous voulez
peut-être que je voulais peut-être que
je les remercie de me traiter de sale
[ __ ] mal et moi je ça ça ne vous a pas
choqué et c'est ça qui me choque moi
mais si ça me choque pourquoi ça me
choque mais non parce que vous le dis
quand même et c'est non mais parce que
vous revenez sur ces gens là qui
rentrent qui tape sur mon public qui
sont 150
ils se croient tout permis il blesse une
petite fille d'origine marocaine pour
marc etienne en a le droit
allons-y et et qui en plus de ça rentre
en criant 'dieu d'eau sale [ __ ] les
juifs auront à pau c'est marqué dans le
journal j'ai quand même le droit de dire
que ce sont des négriers ils ont une
attitude de négriers reconvertis dans la
banque le spectacle et l'action
terroriste
pourquoi tout ça parce qu' il fallait
organiser cette manifestation
c'était dans mon spectacle et c'était
une action terroriste pour vous je n'ai
pas le droit de me défendre et de
répondre aux insultes défendent mais
enfin souffler c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas de pression on a l'impression
d'entendre les propos des extrémistes
des années 30
dans les journaux comme rivarol comme
gringoire et venant de vous c'est
tellement surprenant c'est tellement
inadmissible que j'en suis choqué voilà
mais je comprends que vous puissiez être
choqués mais avouez que ça n'est pas la
même chose de me dire dieu dieu donné tu
as dit les juifs sont tous des négriers
reconvertis dans la banque
est ce que je viens de vous lire ça n'a
rien à voir mais alors quand votre
spectacle a été annulé en février à
l'olympia vous avez été soutenue par des
gens comme guy bedos bruno gaccio
laurent ruquier au nom de la liberté
d'expression puisque le spectacle que
vous jouiez à l'époque s'appelait le
divorce de patrick il n'était pas
question de sionisme maison ou du
conflit du moyen orient
et pourquoi à ce moment-là n'avoir pas
fait amende honorable mais je pense
avoir fait amende honorable mais je ne
reviendrai pas sur mes convictions
politiques à l'intérieur de la
république moi je suis ouvert au débat
je suis un pacifiste j'ai et j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut ouvrir et parler
calmement des choses il y à des sujets
sensibles est tabou on mais il faut les
aborder avec le plus c'est pour ça on a
la chance d'être dans une
en france enfin en europe en
l'occurrence de manière générale dans un
pays où on peut parler on peut
s'exprimer et là pourquoi tout d'un coup
sûr un second ne pourrait pas s'exprimer
c'est ce que je me serais bien pourquoi
on peut pas s'exprimer quoi mais parce
que dans ce pays on a envoyé pendant la
guerre des juifs dans des chambres dans
les chambres à gaz et que ça crée un
petit problème quand même l'algérie on
envoyait pendant 400 ans des centaines
de millions de noirs et blancs n'excuse
pas l'autre et b non mais c'est pourquoi
vous me sortez un exemple d'un d'une
souffrance rigoler avec les belges ne
peut pas rigoler aussi facilement avec
les juifs mais jamais il ya eu dans les
chambres à gaz il ya eu 400 ans
d'esclavagé peut être ça n'a pas empêché
michel leeb de faire un sketch qui m'a
fait marrer où il faisait un noir puis à
la fin il faisait à s'ingérer dans des
narines en parlant des lunettes
bon non mais je dire ça peut faire
marrer les gens en tout cas lui l'a pas
été interdit d'exercer son travail il a
même eu la légion d'honneur
je pense que l'humour on doit laisser
une séance nous parler de cette
souffrance et de la souffrance du peuple
est il que je respecte évidemment que je
ne remet absolument pas en cause même si
parfois les organes en face ont remis en
cause la souffrance des noirs ce qui
pourrait aussi être un petit peu comment
ces délibérations d'excusés l'un par
l'autre
mais oui mais tout ce que vous venez de
me dire là
me dire dieudonné vous ne pouvez pas
comprendre parce qu'il ya eu cette
souffrance
à ce moment là tout le monde a souffert
moi aussi j'ai souffert donc tout le
monde vous pouvez pas me balancer ses
vents dépassent plus importante qu'elle
a mis un décompte que dans ce pays on en
voyait les gens dans des chambres à gaz
uniquement parce qu'ils étaient juifs et
vous vous rendez autre raison et b sans
autre raison on attribue cette tendance
à 0,6 de plaisanter avec ça non mais on
a des portes et sans aucune raison des
hommes des femmes des noirs on les a mis
dans des bateaux on en a jeté la moitié
à bâle et c'est des centaines de
millions de personnes qui ont suivi
donc je dirais n'y a pas de monopole de
la souffrance et je vous je le dois
aussi quand je vous parle de ma
souffrance provoqué un certain respect
par rapport à ses mails tout à fait
voilà c'est tout c'est tout ce que je
demande c'est la jeunesse qui demande
aussi mais je vais
bah ouais mais n'empêche que moi je ne
les jette je n'ai jamais manqué de
respect par rapport à cette souffrance à
aucun moment qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai parlé de quoi j'ai d'un
d'extrémistes de colons israéliens ça
n'a quand même rien à voir avec la
souffrance des juifs pendant la guerre
et vous rendez compte que quelqu'un qui
a toute sa famille qui étaient
exterminés dans un camp de concentration
et et qui voit quelqu'un la télé qui dit
il sera rails
vous vous rendez compte fait je sais pas
ça ça va mais encore une fois si vous
voulez la justice la justice cij avait
dit israël la justice m'aurait
certainement condamné arrêté avec la
justice la justice elle défend une
liberté globale non mais là on parle
entre mecs on parle pas de lui si je
n'allais pas sur la justice ajoute je ne
lis pas ce que c'est le sait la seule
autorité dans une affaire comme celle-là
auquel je peux me soumettre c'est à dire
que là on peut discuter comme qu'on
pourra discuter un ruisseau auteur d'un
bistrot 1 et jouer et je pense que vous
êtes dans la dent dans vos questions
mais c'est normal c'est c'est pour
provoquer le débat et peut provoquer la
discussion dans le sens de la rumeur
alors que la réalité tiré ses marrons
non non je sais c'est pas pour provoquer
le débat c'est que je suis sincèrement
choqué dieu sait si je suis pour la
liberté de création rennais sait ce que
c'est si j'ai accueilli des gens dans
cette émission qu'on dit des conneries
j'ai toujours soutenu parce qu'après
tout on a le droit de tout dire dans ce
pays surtout son service public et vous
le savez mais là je suis choquée fin
avril vous en remettez une couche dans
votre nouveau spectacle qui n'est plus
le divorce de patrick mais mes excuses
et là vous excusez pas du tout en fait
vous
les amis' exclu si c'était mes excuses
dans ton cul ouais j'ai retiré dans ton
cul pour justement comme vous le dites
est dans une posture de nuit début mai
nouveau coup de théâtre au lieu de vous
calmer
j'ai fait encore ballon vous mettez sur
la liste europalestine wii qui a un
discours assez radicale et qui à ce que
non il faut d' importer en france le
conflit alors du proche orient surtout
alors ce qui est ce qui est important
voilà comment ça s'est passé il ya
olivia zemor et nicolas shahshahani les
instigateurs de cette liste tous deux
juifs arrêtés sur quoi vous parlez de
quelqu'un de dire qu'il est juif ou pas
juif honorable ça va finir comme le pen
son nom mais je vais vous étiez pourquoi
vous allez comprendre pourquoi ils
viennent me voir il se présente
d'ailleurs comme tel et me dise voilà
nous on va venir te soutenir at on tond
procès et donc ils sont ils sont venus
ils sont ils ont effectivement manifesté
leur soutien en disant que ce sketch
n'était absolument pas antisémite et le
mans n'y avait aucun souci et ensuite
ils m'ont bon et j'ai gagné ce procès et
puis arrive et les élections et ils ont
monté cette liste et de manière assez
naturelle moi j'étais pour le droit
international pas spécial pas spécialisé
sur la question du proche-orient bon
mais j'ai trouvé ça normal pour le droit
international qui est pour moi la
perspective politique la plus
intéressante de l'est de les suivre
et donc j'ai je les ai suivis pendant
cette période là puis aujourd'hui ce
mouvement devient un mouvement politique
j'ai décidé de prendre mes distances
ouais nan mais vous qui êtes tellement
préoccupés par les problèmes de l'
esclavage ans qui est ce qui est tout à
fait compréhensible encore une fois bon
pourquoi pas vous occuper du rwanda par
exemple pour quoi vous occuper de la
palestine parce que le rwanda civile est
le bon a priori la cc s'est terminée
aujourd'hui enfin le conflit en lui-même
alors que le conflit est très vivant
aujourd'hui en palestine et que c'est
l'illustration d'une crise du droit
international en fait c'est à dire que
les
les hommes et les femmes de bonne
volonté de cette planète se sont mis
autour d'une table prennent des
décisions qui ne sont pas respectés et
donc je trouve que c'est ben voilà pour
éviter que le rwanda ne se reproduise il
faut aujourd'hui soutenir effectivement
le droit international notamment en
palestine mais sans il ya dans mon
esprit absolument aucun parti pris je
pense que tout le monde a le droit à une
paix juste dans cet endroit du monde
mais toujours les d'accord pour que les
palestiniens aient droit à un pays bas
il manquerait plus que ça le problème
c'est que vous avez été viré de cette
liste europalestine
j'ai été viré mais alors vous avez été
dit et ça je peux vous simplement jeu
laissez moi expliquer puis après vous
dirai ce que je n'en avons pas été viré
certes chez moi qui partit donc je
reviens juste juste rétablir cette
vérité c'est j'ai fait une dépêche afp
expliquant que ce mouvement devenait une
un mouvement politique et que je
préférais prendre mes distances et à ce
qu'ils disent et eux ils disent que eux
ils disent qu'ils vous ont viré parce
que vous avez amené dans europalestine
et tourne autour de vous des gens
douteux comme alain soral qu'on a reçu
ici d'ailleurs reçu alain soral et qu'on
recevra plus parce que compte tenu de ce
qu'il a dit on peut pas le recevoir mais
il l'a dit avec ses mots
moi je sais je le connais c'est un c'est
un copain et il n'a absolument rien
d'antisémite c'est un républicain il
s'exprime avec une façon et paraît un
peu rassuré il a dit dans complément
d'enquêté sur france 2 il ya le film
s'est passé sur france 2 il a dit depuis
2500 ans
chaque fois que les juifs met les pieds
quelque part au bout de cinquante ans
ils se font dérouiller est scellé truc
con mais c'est vraiment des propos
d'avant guerre quand c'est des trucs
qu'on a pu entendre de 60 ans oui je
pense qu'il s'en est excusé
je pense que ce qui voulait dire c'était
qui il fallait dans des moments de crise
avoir un peu de d'auto
se regarder un petit peu soit serre on
peut pas rejeter tout le temps la faute
sur les autres c'est pas forcément les
arabes les méchants ce n'est pas
forcément
et c'est ça qui voulait dire il s'est
exprimé de manière un peu brutale je
n'ai pas assumer ses propos vous n'avez
pas assumer mais quand il a dit ça vous
étiez à côté de lui impassible mais
sévère que souriant je vais pas de
choquer non mais si vous voulez vous
l'avais dit je pense que le plus
important est alain soral dont il a été
victime en plus de violence suite à cet
avis est justement alors à un saut valin
soir dédicace des livres dans une
librairie il est agressé vous allé à son
secours vous arrivez après la bagarre
mais enfin vous allez le soutenir encore
même c'est à dire que je vais le
soutenir c'est tout simplement je pense
que ce genre d'artiste parce que c'est
un artiste un libre penseur un peu trash
un peu punk
oui mais je crois que c'est important à
l'heure où on est dans un dans une dans
une expression artistique complètement
commercial de de préserver ce type de
vision ça me paraît important la liberté
d'expression de soral je la respecte
mais je l'invité ici il a dit des choses
terribles et ça m'a été reproché et
c'est donc je ne suis pas en train de
jouer les pères la pudeur ou les saintes
nitouches et je sais je sais mais quand
il dit des trucs comme ça autant que
vous et n'a vous êtes l'un des seuls et
je le dis que devon a je pense avoir une
oreille attentive sur le monde de la
création et de l'art en général et non
pas
il ya des moments où même si on connaît
les gens même si on les a invités on
leur dit non c'est plus possible
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya moins et
encore une fois je ne pensais pas être
là pour parler d'alain mais je sais que
c'est quelqu'un de très sensible est un
artiste particulièrement brillant et je
regrette qu'il soit censuré et bree côté
son dernier ouvrage la le cadre être
censurée de boycotter moi je suis ni un
boycot turn et un censeur non mais c'est
vrai qu'au bout d'un moment quand les
gens rajoute systématiquement et quant
aux extrêmes dans les déclarations
absolument insupportable qui rappelle
les propos les pires des des années 30
on peut plus les invités à la télé même
si on est un libre penseur même si on
pense que tout le monde a le droit de
s'exprimer
non mais je
c'est votre c'est votre ligne éditoriale
je sais pas comment vous faites je pense
que vous avez aussi des pressions vous
pouvez pas faire tout ce que vous voulez
tout à fait un coup d'oeil vous êtes là
oui et non mais c'est pour ça que moi je
vous remercie en tout cas deux est là
donc ça veut dire que je fais ce que je
veux simplement je vous dis ce que je
pense c'est vrai ne serait pas invité 15
jours après le sketch et marc olivier
fogiel
mais ça c'est moi ses joues l'autre en
vous êtes vous seul face à vous même
c'est la preuve c'est que vous êtes là
mais quand vous déclarez par exemple
jeux d'eau je sais pas vous déclarez que
l'antisémitisme n'existe pas 8 c'est pas
vrai l'antisémitisme c'est un truc la
mort mais ils font avec les nazis ça
n'existe pas non mais vous vous rendez
compte de lens qu'il ferait ce que vous
arrivez à 10 je pense qu'ils n'en aient
forum resituer systématiquement les
propos dans le contexte je pense que
l'on peut parler de racisme aujourd'hui
il faut arrêter de parler
d'antisémitisme un antisémitisme
c'est quoi ces heures et s'est coincé
imite ainsi mis deux salles et non mais
ça n'a pas de sens en soi ce mot là n'a
pas de sens donc parlons plutôt de
racisme tout racisme anti-juif séparé
les voilà et on dissocie des formes de
racisme une forme particulière et ça je
pense que c'est un danger grave voilà il
serait il est une part importante dans
le sens de ce que dit mouloud aounit
d'ailleurs je crois que c'est très
important d'aller se battre contre tous
les racismes juillet n'ont en effet
aucun mais oui alors mais ça nous amène
quand même à dire des trucs quand on
vous parle de la shoah vous dites comme
si ça pouvait équilibré quoi que ce soit
d'ailleurs vous dites israël a soutenu
l'afrique du sud dans sa politique
d'apartheid
là les nations unies
se sont réunis et ont dit ce que j'ai
dit c'est simplement moi s'est il suffit
de lire un livre d'ailleurs qui est très
bien d'olivier mukuna un entretien qu on
a été interdite en france pour le moment
ouais mais si vous voulez qui reprend
cette résolution des nations unies qui
dit israël est le dernier pays à
entretenir des relations politiques
nucléaires et financière avec l'afrique
du sud avec l'état raciste d'afrique du
sud donc moi si je ne fais que citer les
nations unies alors maintenant tout le
monde a entretenu des relations avec
l'afrique du sud à l'époque de
l'apartheid non mais tout s'est félicité
des gens ouverts et alors je veux dire
déjà est alors d'accord naître le monde
s'est félicité un moment de ce que de
clerck avait supprimé l'apartheid
oui mais être le dernier à le faire ça
un sens symbolique fort très fort
ouais je crois je si vous voulez mais
quand vous dites par exemple que
l'afrique du sud et israël ont mis au
point ensemble un programme d'épuration
ethnique
non j'ai pas dis ensemble mais c'est ce
que j'ai dit c'est son livre de mukuna
raymond garric c ou hangars i mate et
prix nobel de la paix 2004 je peux pas
faire mieux
en tant que femmes de bonne volonté
comme référence cette femme dit
qu'effectivement le sida elle prétend
que le sida bon je pense que
elle est maître d'elle même quand elle
dit ça elle n'est pas sous la menace
elle dit que le sida est une invention
pour anéantir le peuple noir d'afrique
c'est ça sa théorie bon moi la seule
chose que je dirais aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas faire par rapport
à cette maladie terrible 80% des gens
qui vont mourir de cette maladie sont
noirs ça serait peut-être pas mal quand
même de faire je sais pas une sorte de
une analyse une étude sur les origines
de cette maladie mais complètement
indépendantes les zones en est à penser
que le sida a été consciemment
développer quand vous avez anéantir des
noirs d'afrique non mais moi je ne pense
pas ça mais quand vous avez le prix
nobel de la paix 2004 il reçoit son prix
et nous informe de cette chose je
m'interroge et je dis je ne veux pas y
croire ça me paraît trop atroce mais
vous me citiez tout à l'heure le nazisme
c'est vrai que la folie humaine peut
aller très loin
donc il faudrait peut-être faire une
commission d' enquête sur leurs origines
de cette matière aurait intérêt à
détruire les noirs d'afrique
c'est cette commission d' enquête qui
pourrait nous le nous en informer
maintenant peut-être effectivement une
paranoïa ultime je ne sais pas mais le
fait qu'un prix nobel qu'une femme en
plus formidable on est d'accord
est ce que vous êtes conscient quand
même que que là vous êtes sur une route
qui qui qui vous coupe du reste du monde
quoi vous êtes parti dans votre truc qui
me coûte du reste du show business mais
pas du monde parce que je suis ma salle
est pleine depuis le mois de mai savez
je vois toujours des gens pour aller
voir oui ça le pen il fait 10 9% de deux
suffrages
oui mais je veux moi je suis gens qui
vont aller en améliorant le pen le pen
va changer je me suis battu s'avérer
justement je ne juge pas sur cette ligne
politique on peut même le traité
d'immigration nist moi je pense
qu'effectivement c'est par le brassage
naturel des populations sur cette
planète qu'on arrivera à un équilibre à
une paix c'est mon concept dont je suis
pas nationaliste du tout maintenant me
comparer à le pen non jeu
si vous êtes un provocateur mais et
j'apprécie sa vocation personnes âgées à
coluche et a eu des problèmes de dos
avec des problèmes il est interdit
d'antenne
il ya eu des passes qui s'attaquait au
pouvoir en place parce qu'il s'est
attaqué aux institutions et c'est tout à
fait souhaitable c'est tout à fait bien
on a besoin de gens comme ça
mais est ce que vous vous n'avez pas le
sentiment vous êtes embarqué dans un
truc et d'une façon un peu têtue vous
voulez pas te reconnais c'est mon côté
breton
c'est vrai que ma mère est bretonne
ouais j'ai un côté un peu têtu mais j'ai
quand j'entends que je ne comprends pas
sur le sol j'ai l'impression d'être de
bonne volonté de m excuser si j'ai
blessé des gens qui ne pouvaient pas
comprendre
à partir du moment où je je je dois
aller au bout de ma démarche pour
comprendre et et je crois que c'est fait
on est dans un an on est vous le savez
mieux que moi mais on est dans un pays
où avec une vraie tradition de l'humour
à l'époque s'est elle même à l'époque
des rois c'était y avait le bouffon à la
cour
il mettait la couronne étant entendu
couper la terre mais sans aller chercher
jusque là bal tragique à colombey en
couverture de charlie hebdo quand
général de gaulle bon alors voilà très
bien oui là c'est pas pareil on a
l'impression que vous complaisez
finalement dans cette victimisation dont
vous êtes le seul responsable en fait
c'est un point de vue de me dire ça moi
je
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité mais
je pense que c'est un point de vue qui
est discutable je pense pas je pense
être la victime
et je ne pense pas me parce qu'on m'a
interdit de travailler dans un pays où
je paye des impôts parce que j'ai une
femme et trois enfants à nourrir
parce que je trouve incroyable que dans
un pays comme le mien qui est qui et la
france et qui est enfin plus largement
l'europe je préfère me considérer comme
européen ouais je trouve incroyable que
j'ai pu faire un sketch sur un le mollah
jean-christophe fait plus faire un
sketch sur le curé là je fais un sketch
sur un colon israélien et tout d'un coup
c'est l'hystérie pourquoi parce que vous
avez depuis un an en font c'est le même
clou c'est ce que j'essaye de vous dire
ce soir si vous auriez fait le sketch
chez fogiel
vous auriez libron le sketch était pas
très drôle suis désolé ok bah stats
c'est pas grave moi je vous invite à un
jour ici pour faire
les picards et le gendarme se fait
réussi non plus voilà bon mais c'est pas
grave on l'a dit c'est pas l'argent
d'ormesson je lui ai expliqué jeudi
doublé mais là ça fait un an vous
enfoncer le même coup vous devenez le
représentant maintenant officiel vous
étiez un humour de l'antisémitisme de
l'antisionisme - ouais parce qu'elles
savent après ça vous tombe sur la gueule
un beau matin n'étaient pas préparés
pire tu eu la chiasse et non non c'est
vrai que c'est c'est douloureux sénat
mais là vous êtes devenu maintenant le
spécialiste exemple kankankan le
gouvernement va interdire la chaîne du
hezbollah al manar mais ça c'est un
scandale
voilà j'ai commencé à une pile c'est une
chaîne qui fait un feuilleton basé sur
le protocole des sages de sion dont tout
le monde sait que c'est une invention
c'est une chaîne qui est d'après que
celle israéliens qui ont donné le sida
aux africains non mais on revient sur ce
sujet la défendent et c'est le défense
vous simplement je voudrais en ma mère
et la liberté mais aussi des fans en
tête je voudrais qu'on nous met en
position d'en quête sur les origines de
cette maladie je n'ai je n'ai aucune
certitude sur les choses mais ça me
paraîtrait normal que les nations unies
pour une candidate elle enquête sur les
origines de la grana dit cette chaîne ne
fait que pousser le débat c'est tout
simplement d'où vient cette maladie qui
est né comme ça peut pas défendre al
manar la chaîne du hezbollah au nom de
la liberté d'expression il ya un moment
à quoi vous défendez vous défendez vous
michel vite et bien d'autres chaînes qui
moi qui me dérange dans le dans le
paysage
quand vous avez tfj qui appellent au
boycott de mon spectacle qu'est ce que
c'est que cette chaîne qui représente
quel genre d'intérêt non mais je vous
pose la question vous ne vous choque pas
ça vous choque pas que les chaînes
religieuses interdisent le spectacle
d'un humoriste si ça me choque
comment se fait-il que cette chaîne soit
encore en jeu comprend pas mais bon moi
j'ai jamais vous êtes vous êtes pour le
fait qu al manar soit diffusée en france
avec des feuilletons basés sur les
protocoles des sages de sion exemple non
c'est à la justice un moment donné ça
certains le font non mais là c'est pas
la justice et le csa la justice donnera
raison à la chaîne vous verrez parce
qu'ils n'ont pas a visiblement franchi
cette fameuse limite la propagande qui
est en train de monter grain c'est une
chaîne qui fait mais bon là voyez vous
voyez ce qui se pa laisser la justice
s'exprime là il faut pas il faut pas
crier en même temps que les loups dans
une aubaine parce que il ya une
hypertrophie dans la sensibilité autour
de la question israélienne
hypertrophie soyez raisonnables et vaut
prendre des distances je pense et
laisser la justice se prononcer je pense
pas ce que c'est il ya une hystérique
dire que moi je le vois dans mon métier
d'humoriste aujourd'hui il ya des zones
vraiment compliqué et pourtant c'est des
zones où il faut installer de l'humour
est alors je suis comme un chercheur jeu
c'est vrai que bon jeu on peut se
planter et j'ai pu me planter je suis
pas je ne représente je n'incarne pas la
raison bien loin de là mais de là à
représenter l'axé du mal à moi tout seul
non non jamais donc votre chance chez
l'ex dumas je peux pas représenter de la
non moi je me trouve faut qu'on partage
moi je me trouve non moi je le trouve je
vous le savez bien je cèderai drôle et
en plus très bons comédiens et je suis
un peu désolé pour vous dire la vérité
je vous parle amicalement je suis un peu
désolé de vous voir vous enfoncez là nan
mais parce que c'est peut-être la
dernière fois que je vous invite dieudo
en tout cas mais non mais c'est
courageux de le dire moi je trouve ça
très bien et puis d'ailleurs vous êtes
un des rares personnes avec qui on peut
parler et je sais que quand je vous
parle comme ça on se parlera comme ça
après y'a pas de soucis si je ne suis
plus invité je ne serai plus invité mais
je ne peux pas aller contre ma
conscience c'est contre ma dignité je
peux pas j'ai une dignité j'ai une
conscience
est-ce que vous êtes prêts là avant que
vous êtes prêts là quelle excuse
êtes vous prêt à faire là bas mais comme
je lé fais et je peux peut-être saisir
effectivement l'opportunité d'être face
à vous pour le dire si j'ai blessé des
gens en faisant ce sketch et les autres
sketchs que j'ai fait ici sur ce sketch
précisément si j'ai blessé des musulmans
faisant le mans le mollah
jean-christophe je demande des excuses
je suis désolé si j'ai fait si j'ai
blessé des juifs en faisant de ce je
suis désolé et je m'en excuse
profondément mais sachez que c'est par
le rire qu'on va avancer tous ensemble
et c'est pas on se cristallisant comme
ça parce qu'un repli communautaire
extrêmement de tout à fait au sein de
l'âne de la république il faut faire
attention café bon tu peux je pourrais
je serais peut-être pas réinviter est
bon
on se recroisera j'espère mais en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est que je sais
qu'il ya je suis soutenue par une grande
majorité des français et ça ça et ça ça
fait les français encore une fois en 40
il soutenait tous pétain donc la
majorité des français
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait pour moi
j'ai rien fait et ce que vous auriez été
courageux vous à l'époque j'en sais rien
ce que moi j'aurais été courageux qui ça
vient a fait j'en sais rien moi pendant
la traite négrière qu'est ce que
j'aurais fait est ce que j'aurai pas
trahi les miens qu'est-ce que je comment
j'aurais réagi je ne joue pas pour
conclure est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pensez pas que vous auriez mieux à faire
à faire avancer la cause des noirs en
france c'est quelque chose qui me
préoccupe
oui il ya un vrai racisme entre mise à
l'écart des gens de couleur d'en rire
dans ce pays
moi quand j'invite des musulmans dans
cette émission tout le monde me regarde
comme si c'était extraordinaire alors
que m'a quand même 6 millions dans ce
pays
est ce que vous auriez pas intérêt
finalement à faire avancer la cause des
noirs plutôt que d'être la nuit de l'aco
sioniste c'est sur mais bon tout a
commencé avec ce projet de film sur le
cibler sur le sur le code noir sur la
traite négrière tout a commencé comme ça
je vais voir les autorités de mon pays
le cnc pour dire bon là je voudrais
faire ce film et l'on me dit on m'envoie
un croyant dean on ne fait pas un film
avec moi parce que c'est un sujet
extrêmement délicat 95 % des richesses
aux antilles appartiennent encore
descendants d'esclaves nice c'est un
sujet difficile à ouvrir
alors je leur dis venez vous pouvez pas
me dire ça vous avez financé tout un tas
de films sur d'autres crimes contre
l'humanité le mien c'était été déclaré
comme crime contre l'humanité vous ne
pouvez pas me et là j'ai compris que
j'étais face à une sorte de d'unis cité
dans la souffrance face à la république
qui m'a extrêmement déranger et là j'ai
eu un discours qui est celui que j'ai
face à vous et je ne changerai pas c'est
pour ça que je vous dit peut-être que ce
discours ne passera pas mais tant que
les noirs n'auront pas le droit aussi à
leur dignité et simplement à leur
histoire
je tiendrai ce discours et je
continuerai à le faire et qui a intérêt
à pas faire ce film on peut vous dire
que ça marchera pas que ça fera pas
d'entrée mais personne peut vous dire
que alors pas bien de le faire vous vous
connaissez les cadets scanner la france
aujourd'hui
si je vous dis ce que je vous dis c'est
que oui j'ai vraiment fait les choses
dans l'ordre et le mieux du monde c'est
à dire que c'est aux points de départ
c'était au synopsis cirque sur quelques
lignes juste sur le sujet elle m'a dit
c'est ce sujet n'est pas un sujet de
film fait un documentaire qui dit mais
pourquoi pas un spectacle de
marionnettes
si vous êtes malade je veux dire il ya
on est combien de millions de noirs dans
ce pays on a simplement
et encore une fois je suis pas
communautaire du tout
ma mère est blanche mon père et noir je
dis simplement une chose la moindre des
choses c'est que le peuple noir a le
droit à son histoire
oui bien sûr nous ne sommes pas nos
ancêtres n'étaient pas des gaulois mais
nous sommes français et nous avons le
droit de savoir comment ça s'est passé
alors pourquoi on ne veut pas ouvrir ce
dossier mais parce que quand on veut
ouvrir ce dossier qui a profité de cette
cire que l'on va voir on va avoir des
shows on va comprendre un peu mieux
l'histoire et ça va gêner sa gêne des
gens lynx si si j'ai déjà si j'avais pu
faire ce film comme ça je serais pas là
aujourd'hui parce que les choses ne se
seraient pas passées ne serait pas
d'erreurs et c'est bien là mais alors
donc justement par rapport à ça la seule
façon aujourd'hui que j'ai 2 2 pour
faire ce film c'est d'organiser une
souscription
c'est la souscription pour le code noir
et donc je l'organisé ça je pense que et
la population qui a envie de voir ce
film doit savoir qu' il ne pourra pas se
faire par le canal historique du cinéma
donc théâtre de la main d'or
associations le code noir on a monté une
association
souscrivez et puis je pense que c'est se
réapproprier son histoire et c'est très
important pour toute une population qui
aujourd'hui est malade mais si on peut
vous aider l'action le forum
merci et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu